everybody say hello to Tucker
a warm welcome to Tucker Carlson anyway
we appreciate a great show Welcome to
Hannity we are back with our live studio
audience and tonight big announcement
the Biden Administration is now breaking
one record after another not one of them
in any good way in 2021 Biden set a new
record with the most illegal border
crossings in U.S history then in 2022
yeah right in 2022 he broke his own
record with even more illegal border
crossings and guess what this year
Joey's on pays to do it once again with
a whole new record high but according to
the most idiotic people that work in the
White House Joe Biden he's not at fault
it's not his problem we didn't have this
problem when the last Administration
Biden ended almost all of Trump's border
protections and halted construction of
the border wall ended the state of
Mexico policy and told illegal
immigrants come one come all there's no
vetting uh not even vetting during a
pandemic as far as health issues now
according to DHS secretary Alejandro
mayorkas his boss Joe Biden he is just
not responsible no you'll never guess
what really is responsible
climate change he thinks I know he
thinks there are climate refugees all
over the world and there is just nothing
that the president can do about it it's
the climate's fault take a look
when we speak about the Border we have
to put it in context that this is not a
challenge and it is indeed a challenge
not a challenge exclusive to the United
States you know Chile just deployed its
military to its border Colombia has 2.5
million Venezuelans within its borders
Costa Rica's population is increasingly
Nicaraguan we are seeing a movement of
people throughout the hemisphere and
quite frankly throughout the world that
is historic the way to say it aren't
these the same people that tell us again
and again and again that your border is
secure that's what I recall do you
recall that take a look
sounds to most folks like a crisis well
look it's way down now we've now gotten
control precisely that the border is
closed nor could I have been clearer and
continue to be so which is the border is
closed the United States will continue
to enforce our laws and secure our
border the Border we are working to make
the Border more secure you're confident
this border is secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for Any
Nation including ours in our
Administration we agree that the border
is secure oh okay uh now of course it's
not just who crosses the borders
unlawfully by the way think of all the
drugs that cross that border lethal
drugs pouring into our country and this
leads us to yet another Biden record and
that is the number of fentanyl deaths
more Americans sadly are now dying from
fentanyl than ever before now keep in
mind most of that fentanyl that is made
in China it is shipped to Mexico
smuggled across the wide open Southern
border a record 100
000 plus Americans died from drug
overdoses in just the last year this
current federal government is now
controlled by a group of woke idiots and
now what there are really only a few
things certain in Biden's America Let's
see we get record inflation uh death
that's guaranteed in anybody's in
America higher taxes for every American
now as we speak excess deaths are at a
record high even though the pandemic is
in the rear view mirror and Americans
are now paying more taxes than they've
ever paid before this includes the new
taxes that Joe Biden just implemented
225 Billion Dollar corporate tax hike on
corporations that will get passed on to
you the consumer I make the case all the
time corporations don't pay taxes okay
they charge more for their goods and
services it's that simple we pay it now
Joe's 71 billion dollar tax on your
retirement funds okay you say for
retirement now we're going to tax that
and Joe's multi-billion dollar tax on
those who end up powering their homes
with natural gas Joe's 12 billion dollar
tax on crude oil Joe's billion dollar
tax on coal uh guess what all the people
in this country are impacted by this and
Joe promised he'd never raise taxes on
any American that made under four
hundred thousand dollars a year now the
war on American Energy doesn't stop
there Biden is reportedly Now set to
reject what is a massive new oil and gas
project in Alaska now at the same time
Biden opened up oil imports from the
Hostile uh regime socialist nation of
Venezuela where we now buy three million
barrels of crude oil every single month
now Joe is impoverishing you and your
families and making countries what like
Venezuela and China and Russia Rich
again does that make sense we have high
paying career jobs it's good for our
national security and guess what it is
the lifeblood of the world's economy and
don't forget importing oil comes with a
cost that cost is passed on to you the
American people in other words a hidden
tax on every single gallon of gas that
you buy it also raises the cost of
heating and cooling your home and now
yet another tax hike after blasting
Republicans over that secret plan to
upend Medicare remember during the State
of the Union Address Biden now wants to
increase taxes on Medicare so it turns
out Joe Biden was right there were
people in Washington with a secret plan
it was him he has a secret plan to
increase the cost of Medicare at the
very same time Joe wants to give
government workers what it will be the
largest pay increase in 43 years by the
way if you work for the government you
already make more money on average than
people in the private sector of course
Biden already gifted 36 billion of your
dollars to the Teamsters Union to bail
out their badly managed pension fund it
was the largest private pension bailout
in the history of the country but what
is a few billion dollars among friends
right keep in mind the Teamsters Union
they extort blue collar workers they
then donate that money to elect
Democrats like Joe Biden but today on
Capitol Hill all the Teamsters Union
president accused Republican senator
Mark Wayne Mullen Being Greedy why
because Mullen owned a family business
take a look
what job have you created one job other
than sucking a paycheck
out of some other body somebody else
that you want to say that you're trying
to provide because you're forcing them
to pay dues no we don't force us you're
out alive no don't tell me you are
online don't tell me I'm out of line
well you you don't tell me you frame
you're throwing the Stables yeah because
you don't know you're gonna tell me to
shut my mouth Yes I do pull it yeah hold
it you haven't created a job we haven't
you haven't been there you haven't sure
we have you haven't sure we have tell me
one job that you created what are you
talking about be specific you're an
employer
oh yeah you are but he didn't create a
single job he couldn't answer that
question now that brings us to someone
even more entitled and more Sleazy and
Biden's or orbit and that is his own son
Hunter Biden now the president's son is
any fans of Hunter here anyway uh the
president's son is now desperate to
slash child support payments owed to the
now four-year-old little girl that
Hunter fathered with a former stripper
from Arkansas while he was dating his
brother's widow okay
you can't make it up but with that said
I don't really care about hunter's
messed up private life that's his
private personal life fine that's all
said and done uh but here's the sad part
there's not one member of the Biden
family that is willing to recognize this
four-year-old little girl in any way
they all pretend like she doesn't exist
you know aside from court ordered child
support that Hunter is forced to pay out
this girl is precious and she is
innocent and Joe the president and Jill
his wife what they don't have it in
their heart to even want to meet their
own granddaughter but now if Hunter
wants what a reduction in those payments
he's going to have to prove that he has
financial hardship in a court of law
which might be hard since Hunter is
reportedly selling his amateur paintings
I call them portraits of a crack addict
uh
for up to five hundred thousand dollars
a piece now why would anyone pay that
much for a terrible paint by numbers
amateur painting I don't know but there
are people's that are buying them but
they won't tell us who's buying them
okay probably someone where you know is
paying for access to his father look the
Biden family reeks of corruption
incompetence it's not just Biden's age
and mental and cognitive decline his
presidency has been a train wreck and
that's why even Democrats say are very
hesitant to support Joe Biden for a
second term take a look
would you support President Biden
running for re-election 24. if he runs
for a re-election sure
in that same vein
are you going to endorse Joe Biden if he
runs for reelection
oh there's plenty of time for the
election this is the problem with
America right now we start an election
every time there's a cycle he's the
leader of your party I I
no the bottom line is let's see who's
involved let's wait until we see who all
the players are let's just wait until it
all comes out doesn't sound very
confident to me all right whoever gets
nominated in the Democratic party will
be bolstered by a system of legal ballot
harvesting now Biden is now accused of
weaponizing voter turnout unlawfully on
the federal level with an executive
order that enables the USCIS to register
new citizens at Naturalization Services
as well as the Department of Education
to push voter registration to any
student taking out a college loan and
that's not all the justice department is
now getting voter information to federal
prisoners that's what they get they get
to vote from jail put it in a Dropbox
God knows where it's going to end up
anyway according to a former president
Trump the best way now to counter these
efforts and Republicans you better pay
attention you better adapt and you
better adjust you better get over your
reluctance and resistance to voting by
mail and voting early and you better
meet and probably defeat the Democratic
efforts at legal ballot harvesting based
on state law these efforts by the way is
the only way you'll get in the game or
otherwise you'll start out election day
down you know 500 000 votes that's hard
to make up on Election Day anyway take a
look
many states have banned ballot
harvesting to keep our elections honest
and fair but in the states where ballot
harvesting is still legal we have no
choice but to beat the Democrats at
their own game it's very simple either
we start ballot harvesting
or you can say goodbye to our country
you can just wave goodbye because
Democrats would win every single
election we have to get smart with your
help we will Master the Democrats game
of ballot harvesting and we will win
back the White House from Joe Biden and
the people that are destroying our
country they're absolutely destroying
America thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else